[Music]
these candy wafers come in eight
different flavors
the original roll has a random
assortment of 38 pieces part of the fun
is seeing how many of your favorite
flavors you get this factory makes one
flavor at a time the first step is to
add food coloring and flavoring to
pulverized sugar this pink color and
mint flavoring produces a winter green
taste corn syrup comes next along with a
binding solution of vegetable gums and
gelatin dissolved in water after mixing
for about eight minutes the candy
dough's consistency is checked workers
divide the dough into chunks then feed
them into a dough sheeter they're pushed
through a slot forming a dough sheet
that's 20 inches wide by about an inch
thick a steady sprinkle of cornstarch
prevents the sheet from sticking to the
equipment rollers compress and stretch
the dough forward flattening the sheet
to an inch thick the next station stamps
on the company logo then cuts out the
wafers
the conveyor belt moves the wafers to a
multi-level tunnel dryer they pass
through the dryer 13 times over the
course of an hour once out of the dryer
the wafers pile up in trays without
sticking workers stack the trays in a
drying room it's heated and humidified
with steam the candy wafers stay here
until their moisture level drops to
between 0.75 and 1% the factory tests a
few samples using a device called a pen
a trauma tur it measures the force
required to penetrate the candy wafer to
the point of breaking it this ensures
the candies are the correct consistency
when the trays come out of the drying
room workers send the candies to the
packaging line the colors are mixed
together ensuring every roll of candy
has a random assortment of flavors
[Music]
workers grabbed about two rolls worth
then fill two channels of a feeder that
takes them to the wrapping station
[Music]
another worker fills in the gaps
ensuring each roll has 38 pieces the
wrapping machine cuts printed
translucent paper wrapping and applies a
bead of glue to one edge in a matter of
seconds the Machine lifts the roll into
the wrapper seals the edges and twist
the ends closed